Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Les quiero contar que
yo soy una artista política.
Soy de una generación que creyó
que el arte iba a cambiar el mundo.
Así que, desde que me pensé artista,
intento que mi práctica sea
de resistencia y de transformación.
Pero, como que
mi destino ha sido ser artista.
Por ejemplo, mi mamá era pintora.
Ella se murió cuando yo era muy chica,
así que de alguna manera la pintura
fue la única opción que tuve.
Fue como la manera que yo encontré
de estar cerca de ella.
Comencé a pintar a fin de los 80,
y no era un lenguaje cómodo la pintura.
La verdad que no me resultaba fácil,
pero era lo que tenía a mano.
Y soy feminista.
Y lo que más me gusta es descubrir,
entender que yo lo descubrí,
transitando en la práctica, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, en los años 90
pintaba sobre unas telas negras,
ropa interior femenina
con objetos de uso doméstico.
Esas telas iban colgadas sobre
unos soportes de madera en cruz
y para mí eran como grandes estandartes
para una manifestación
de mujeres en la calle.
Después pinté todos los métodos
anticonceptivos femeninos.
Como que en todo mi trabajo
siempre estaba instalado
toda la reflexión sobre
la violencia doméstica.
Pero en los años 90, la verdad
es que el arte discutía otras cosas
y mi trabajo no circulaba, así que
yo tenía una gran frustración.
Estaba enojada porque mandaba
a los concursos de pintura
y me rechazaban sistemáticamente.
Así que un día decidí:
"dejo el arte, me voy a poner
un bar en la playa".
Comencé a levantar mi taller, enojada.
Y ordenaba, poniendo algunas cosas
momentáneamente en la pared,
que las sostenía con cinta de pintor.
Un día viene a verme un amigo y me dice,
"che, pero qué buena esa obra".
Y yo me quedé como sorprendida,
y cuando él se fue, me quedé
pensando y fui a la cocina,
abrí el cajón de los cubiertos
y saqué pinches, espátulas,
tenedores, cucharas, cuchillos,
y repetí el gesto de encintarlos
a la pared con la cinta de pintor.
Ese gesto se convirtió en una obra
que formó parte de una gran instalación
que yo llamé "Material Escéptico".
Como que esos instrumentos
eran un archivo para mí
de objetos de uso cotidiano
que se convertían en
instrumentos quirúrgicos
para un aborto casero y clandestino.
Toda esa pieza reflexionaba sobre
la violencia en la ilegalidad del aborto.
Y yo seguía incómoda de todos modos.
Sentía que todo mi trabajo
todavía estaba instalado
en una especie de arte
grandilocuente, pretencioso.
Para mí, ahora entiendo
como "deconstrucción patriarcal".
Como que en ese afán de ser
esa artista como ideal,
estaba externa a mí.
Y un día me pasó, que de golpe
empecé a darme cuenta
de que estaba envejeciendo.
De golpe, con 45 años, me convertí
en una mujer menopáusica.
Conocí una violencia totalmente distinta.
Desaparecía, no sé, ese olor
de una aparente fertilidad útil
y dejaron de mirarme.
Desaparecí de todo posible horizonte.
Así que yo no sabía bien
qué hacer con eso, la verdad.
Y tenía que reinventarme.
Y decidí transitarlo,
obviamente, en mi práctica.
Tenía que pensar en hacer
una pieza, una obra,
que diera visibilidad
a estas nuevas emociones.
Así que decidí buscar mujeres,
mujeres que en ese momento
tenían más de 60 años,
que quisieran charlar conmigo
y que me ayudaran un poco
a contar esto que nos pasa.
Y mi obra dio otro giro,
totalmente distinto.
Así que desde esa época
que yo vengo trabajando
en la construcción de una obra artística.
Que se compone de acciones,
de performances, de videos
y que llamo "Escuela de Envejecer".
Que es donde intento dar visibilidad
a la violencia del envejecimiento.
Trabajo con estas mujeres jubiladas,
y que en la actualidad
están haciendo por ejemplo,
todas esas actividades que quisieron
hacer cuando eran jóvenes,
esas actividades deseadas,
y que no pudieron porque tenían
que trabajar, cuidar hijos, el marido.
Pero por sobre todas las cosas,
no pudieron hacerlo por todos los
prejuicios y prohibiciones que se tenía,
sobre todo en esa época,
para con el género.
Yo les pido a ellas que sean maestras
de esas actividades actuales, deseadas.
Que se conviertan realmente en
esas maestras de sus deseos frustrados.
Que son muy poderosas ahora.
En una primera instancia
-- como que se divide en dos partes --
me junto con ellas,
en espacios íntimos de mucho afecto
y damos forma a estas acciones
con todas sus emociones
y con la intensidad de sus recuerdos.
Por ejemplo, hace unos años
me invitaron a una trienal en Brasil
y trabajé con una mujer
que en ese momento tenía 87 años,
que se llama Mariko Sakata,
de origen japonés.
Ella había tenido, obviamente, una vida
muy dura, de mucho trabajo,
así que cuando se jubiló no sabía
qué hacer con su tiempo libre.
¿Qué hizo?
Recurrir a sus deseos postergados,
que, obviamente, eran el baile y el canto.
Armó un cuerpo de baile
de danzas japonesas
con sus amigas de un club social
al que todas iban.
Todas entre 70 y más de 90 años.
Las juntó a todas y Mariko les enseñaba
todas las coreografías que ella inventaba
y además diseñaba todo el vestuario
que cosía y pintaba a mano
para cada una de sus amigas.
Así que cuando yo la conocí le pedí
por favor que me enseñara a bailar.
También Mariko cumplió
su sueño de ser cantante
y se convirtió en una
campeona regional de karaoke.
Obviamente, le pedí por favor
que me enseñe a cantar karaoke.
En una segunda instancia,
estas acciones o esto que
hacemos en el espacio íntimo,
sale ya diseñado al espacio público.
Y damos esos talleres performáticos
a un público general
en el marco de una exhibición,
generalmente en una institución artística.
Para mí, Escuela de Envejecer
nos obliga a subirnos
a nuestros deseos frustrados.
Como que no hay manera de evitar eso.
Intento darle valor
al capricho y al fracaso,
como valores académicos,
como saberes académicos.
También intentando un poco discutir
con el sistema del arte
que suele ser bastante
autoritario y prejuicioso
con respecto al saber.
Siento que esta obra también
propone terminar con esa violencia
que ha estado en nuestra
vida de mujeres desde siempre.
Y revisando también un poco
toda mi historia artística
me doy cuenta de que
sigo siendo esa artista
que todavía sigue intentando
hacer una práctica
de resistencia y de transformación.
Ahora quiero compartir con Uds.,
y que sean parte también
un poco de mi trabajo.
Yo cumplí uno de mis sueños
gracias a Mariko Sakata,
yo siempre quise ser de
una banda de rock, supongo todos.
Pero yo cumplí el sueño con mis amigas,
artistas visuales todas,
hicimos una banda de karaoke.
Nos llamamos
"Las Desesperadas por el Ritmo".
Y hoy están acá, van a subir
al escenario y me van a acompañar.
Y quiero que todos se paren.
Parensé todos. Arriba, todos.
Y vamos a cantar y bailar un fragmento
de una canción que nos gusta mucho,
que se llama "Resistiré".
Acá están todas mis amigas.
Son muy grosas porque están acá
y vamos a cantar todos un karaoke,
la canción que se llama "Resistiré",
que supongo que la conocen.
(Comienza la música)
Todos canten, ¿eh?
♪ Cuando pierda todas las partidas ♪
♪ Cuando duerma con la soledad ♪
♪ Cuando se me cierren las salidas ♪
♪ Y la noche no me deje en paz ♪
♪ Cuando sienta miedo del silencio ♪
♪ Cuando cueste mantenerme en pie ♪
♪ Cuando se rebelen los recuerdos ♪
♪ Y me pongan contra la pared ♪
♪ Resistiré, erguido frente a todo ♪
♪ Me volveré de hierro
para endurecer la piel ♪
♪ Y aunque los vientos
de la vida soplen fuerte ♪
♪ Soy como el junco que se dobla ♪
♪ pero siempre sigue en pie ♪
♪ Resistiré, para seguir viviendo ♪
♪ Soportaré los golpes
y jamás me rendiré ♪
♪ Y aunque los sueños
se me rompan en pedazos ♪
♪ Resistiré, resistiré ♪
(Fin de la música)
(Risas)
(Aplausos)